It played over to come back,
uh,
today I think he would have a lot to say
about so many things,
but,
but crowd sourcing would be of great
interest to him.
I take plato to the Google plex and he's
very,
very interested in our technology and,
uh,
that,
that would appeal to him very much.
Um,
but he gets into a conversation at the
Google plex with a software engineer on
a crowdsourcing and could crowdsourcing
answer the kind of ethical questions
that he first raised.
And,
um,
he is,
he's quite interested in this idea,
but he's very,
uh,
he's very down.
He's very much against it because,
you know,
he doesn't,
he didn't have much of a faith in the
ethical opinions of the masses.
He thought that ethics was a kind of
knowledge,
um,
that is extremely hard to attain.
He's right.
I mean,
that's one of the reasons we've left him
so far behind.
It's slowly,
slowly where we make progress,
ethical,
ethical progress.
Uh,
but he thought it was a kind of
knowledge and it takes a trained mind
and,
um,
you know,
it's harder than mathematics.
Mathematics is a preparation for this
kind of knowledge that you need,
that kind of dispassion and distance
and,
uh,
from your own life to be able to access
ethical knowledge.
So he would not have been very
interested in crowdsourcing and what is
the opinion of the masses of people.
And he also would say,
I think,
well then,
how do we ever make any ethical
progress?
How do we ever learn anything new,
um,
to,
to challenge our,
our intuitions,
if in fact it's just being crowdsourced.
I do have Plato,
I'm getting quite addicted to the
Internet and looking up things on,
on the Jana wikipedia constantly.
I mean,
that was partly,
I,
I needed a quick way to bring him up to
speed.
Uh,
and,
and he is constantly,
we carries,
he gets,
well while he's at the Google plex,
he gets a chromebook.
Um,
may give them a chromebook and he,
he carries it with him everywhere.
I mean,
he's constantly consulting it.
Uh,
but again,
he is,
um,
he believed in,
in the expert.
Uh,
he believed,
you know,
an expertise.
Uh,
he,
um,
aristotle,
his student was actually says some
things that are much more,
um,
uh,
continent or a favorable toward
crowdsourcing.
You know,
he says that,
you know,
if you,
um,
go to,
uh,
a meal,
if it's just cooked by one person,
you may not like it.
But if it's a feast with many,
many people bringing their dishes,
you'll find something to like,
uh,
aristotle says,
and he really has an idea.
They're a of crowdsourcing.
Let's,
let's try to get as many points of view
as possible.
Plato is,
is very dubious of this.
He,
he believes that it's extremely
difficult to know anything.
It takes a tremendous amount of
training,
years and years of training.
Um,
he has the rulers of his state studying
advanced mathematics for 10 years before
they can even think about political
philosophy.
That's how hard he thinks these things
are.